روسيا امطرت سماء اوكرانيا بالمسيرات
اطلقت موسكو اكثر من 30 مسيره هجوميه
وصارو خين باتجاه شمال وجنوب اوكرانيا
تمكنت انظمه الدفاع الجوي من اسقاط 22 من
المسيرات كما ذكرت في هذا البيان مناطق
الهجوم الرئيسيه كانت في الجنوب والشمال
تمكنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه وقوات
الدفاع من تدمير 22 طائره مسيره من طائرات
العدو ولم تصل العديد من الطائرات المسيره
الاخرى لاهدافها وللمره الثانيه في غضون
24 ساعه اطلقت روسيا صواريخ على خركي ثاني
كبرى المدن في الشرق منطقه كانت قد سيطرت
عليها القوات الروسيه في بدايه الحرب لكن
اخرجت منها بعد شهر وما زالت اليوم منطقه
خاركيف تشهد قصفا متكررا بالمسيرات
والصواريخ وفي ظل استمرار القصف حذرت كيف
يوم الاربعاء دول الغرب بان الذخائر لديها
ستنفد ان لم تحصل على المزيد من الامدادات
ولبحث ذلكك اجتمع الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن مع زعماء الكونغرس في البيت الابيض
من اجل حظ الجمهوريين خصوصا على رفع
التجميد عن المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
لكن الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب يطالبون في
المقابل بتشديد واضح لسياسات
الهجره الاجتماع كان مثمرا اتفهم اهميه
المساعده المقدمه لاوكرانيا وان هناك
مخاوف بشان سلامه اوكرانيا وامنها
واستقلالها الذاتي ولكن الشعب الامريكي
لديه نفس المخاوف ويطلب الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن 61 مليار دولار لموصل المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا